what I love about you flu is you're
consistent always with the fanny pack
yes always for safety well you know when
you have some tied tied to denims where
do you put your important items yes
you forgot the fanny pack hello
Pennypack and you are here what do you
have in there you have precious goodness
so we have some we have some some phone
like ringy-dingy hello mama yeah Oh what
is a good idea I don't know slappa
slappa slappa you know here it is you
know chapstick you know and then etc all
right well there you go curious about
the how many packs you have because I've
never seen you wear the same one twice
and I've met you many times it's true I
am the Imelda Marcos of fanny packs I
have 37 going on 38 finger crossing okay
she'll get one yeah I've always been
fascinated what was fool like as a boy
and then I found this picture of you
that I yes you're so adorable if only
your pajamas had fit they don't look
like they fit what are you holding there
what is that that is the most precious
delicious dessert of history it's called
the fat a mint is that that is it's a
fast mint or something fat mint I was
stranded in the morning as I go to sneak
to the candy place which was just at war
in the kitchen yeah and then I would eat
those if you see the photo yes that's a
big thing in in in Germany is the fossa
me in my whole house we would house on
my in my abode yeah yeah I cannot speak
for other abodes yeah you know I don't
mean about it but you what did you like
about the fossa mint oh it was delicious
have you had before this it's not it's
not good like York poopie patty of minty
Pat it's a hyper mint pad of york
peppermint pattie yeah okay agree to no
one calls it a poopie patty
perhaps a short if they have tried fat
summons a delicious candy from the 80s
in Germany yeah very minty very
delicious I would eat one every five
minutes : wait you and you would eat a
fast him in every five minutes yes there
are 12 in the box so in one hour I've
consumed them all I would look at my
grandfather's clock and then I would
stare then I would munch and chew and
swallow it's a note get excited and then
just as the down comes to get up again
with more
wait a bit so Flula so it's very it
sounds so German to me it is so
disciplined too there are 12 that I will
each one every five minutes I will I
will be disciplined about it well have
you seen before is a cocky span do what
does he do with the Fox iment he munches
it all up in two seconds then has a nice
duty time in his sad yeah if he just
made a little rationing a little of a
shilling
what would he here yeah the purest of
Happy's yeah okay
you